bonjour
tel que vous me voyez la curiosité qui
est en vilain défaut est en train de me
dévorer
pourquoi et bien le facteur qui était en
retard dans sa tournée m'a demandé de
porter ce paquet à François
j'aimerais bien savoir ce qu'il y a
dedans évidemment le paquet est pas gros
mais c'est peut-être quelque chose qui
se mange et ça a beau ne pas être gros
c'est peut-être quand même très bon
tant pis prends soin
il n'est pas là ça tombe bien je vais en
profiter pour jeter un petit coup d'œil
discrètement dans le paquet très vite je
leur fermerai après
zut alors il manquait plus que ça le
papier collant me reste accroché au noir
moi j'entends quelqu'un sur le reste
François bon il faut que je cache le
paquet derrière l'arbre là ce sera très
bien
voilà ni vu Nico
je dois faire
je ne peux pas monsieur du snorba
mademoiselle futé
voilà merci Jojo je suis vraiment touché
dans votre sollicitude
je reviendrai chercher le parquet quand
il aura terminé sa sieste
ouh là là il fait chaud tout de même
je vais défaire un petit peu ma cravate
[Rires]
il fait tellement chaud
c'est indispensable
Casimir
je veux bien mais doucement
c'est vraiment malin
au revoir
à mon ami Léonard
bonjour mademoiselle
très intéressant et qu'est-ce qu'il me
vaut la joie de vous voir dans le jardin
et vous aussi
et je dois savoir sans doute possible à
quel pays ils appartiennent et bien
écoutez nous allons appeler les enfants
ils vont vous aider
c'est l'Italie
ce drapeau c'est la Belgique l'Espagne
[Applaudissements]
la Russie
URSS parfait
ne t'inquiète pas tout va s'arranger
urgent
le voilà merci
il est pas bien gros hein
il a l'air bien fermé
[Musique]
un gros rouleau de papier collant